hey guys Pete here so I'm picking up
with my mr. robot season one rewatched
today today we're gonna look at when am
I not so favorite episodes to be honest
but it's still an important one so we're
gonna look at season 1 episode 2 it was
called ones and zeroes and I think that
well I'll tell you when I first started
watching mr. robot I watched it after
the season originally aired so I watched
it in a binge season one that is and I
was really compelled by the pilot I
thought it was great I liked everything
about it for the most part and then this
episode when I watched it I was a little
bit put off and I think I ended up
putting a little bit of time in between
watching the next one and then I quickly
fell right back into it so I just wanted
to point that out I think compared to a
lot of TV shows it's fine but I think
this is one of the episodes that it
develops characters but because we are
early in meeting everything and trying
to figure out what's going on I don't
think that I felt hooked in to like what
was going on enough and I'll just go
through what happened and I'll talk at
the end a little bit about what put me
off a little and then you know how that
sort of worked itself out as the season
continued so it starts out right where
we left off we see Elliot in the big
conference room at the E Court building
we saw him get picked up and taken there
by mysterious guys in an SUV we found
out tyrell wellick was there and then we
find out that it's not as ominous and
crazy as it looked he's just trying to
hire him and you know rami malek does a
great job as he always does of being
feeling you know acting as though he's
completely out of his element there he
tells well like that he wants to have
some time to think about it Tyrell tries
to put the pressure on him and
eventually Elliott says no I'm good
where I'm at so for the second time in
the series we see him walk away with
some money in the first episode Ron
offered him a bribe he said he wasn't
into it for the money and here you know
Tyrell told him that he would make him a
multi-millionaire within a couple of
years and you
pretty much can believe that that would
have happened Elliot decides to leave
instead and then mr. Southerland the
driver of the SUV who we don't exactly
know what he does except for he works
for Tyrell he drops him back off at his
place as Elliot's coming in he sees
Shayla outside with her drug dealer boss
who will get to meet a little bit later
and we find out when he goes inside that
Elliot's definitely ramping up his drug
use likewise talked about it in the last
recap you know he he talks about how he
has this great plan to control the
uncontrollable and you kind of know that
it's gonna get out of hand and it does
he then hacks Tyrell and because it's
easy and because everything looks really
normal he gets paranoid right away and
he wipes all of his drives he destroys
them and he throws them away outside in
a trash can
and we see him grab a picture of his mom
at the beach like him and his mom
standing on the beach when he was a kid
so why is he using more drugs well it
seems like it's partly paranoia and
partly just because drugs are addictive
so he's getting the excuses that he
needs to dive deeper into it he see a
couple times in this episode that he's
starting to question what's happened in
relation to his working with eff society
but it's more of a like he's just he's
not sure you know he wants to do
something he wants to change the world
but he's not really sure about these
people that he's very much in bed with
now and like I said it's it's rami malek
is what saves this all the way around I
mean his performance he just he does
this really well he becomes a tortured
person who can't really figure out which
ways up but he knows he's gonna fall if
he doesn't do something beyond that not
too much else happens as far as the main
story we do get some stuff you know we
get Gideon congratulating him for saving
the company and gives him a raise and
then we see the eff society video that
was released and this was one of those
things that I just really was sort of
like I mean I can't that they want to
make this I don't know
I guess they want to make it seem
relevant to the way that things happen
in real life it just seems really kind
of comic II to me and you know they make
some really crazy demands that nobody's
obviously gonna find agreeable
it's basically they're making an empty
threat it's like they're you know
they're they offer this deal that no one
would make so it's kind of just like
making noise do you know what I mean
another thing that happens here is that
when Elliott comes back to his house at
one point Darlene who we haven't really
met officially yet is inside his shower
taking a shower and they talked a little
bit and we don't really know Elliott's
freaked out by her being there and she
ends up taking him back to Coney Island
they're mr. robot explains that he has
to really has a really big idea of how
he's gonna destroy the off-site data
storage facility that evil Corp has it's
called Iron Mountain and he's gonna blow
up a gas pipeline and that's gonna blow
up that building and a lot of people are
gonna die and Elliott's not into it mr.
robot kind of makes a decent argument
for his approach but Elliot's definitely
not going to do that and so he basically
walks away there was a good there's a
good speech there from Christian Slater
as mr. robot about being a 1 or being a
zero that's it's it's pretty good I
would say
but his push on Elliot it doesn't work
so Elliot leaves and he's basically
disconnected from F society at this
point so I guess if you had to put it
all together what happens there is
Shayla gets into a bad situation with
her boss Fernando and he's a slimy guy
he drugs her basically and he sleeps
with her she wakes up in the bathtub not
knowing how she got there after they
have you know Elliot and Fernando have a
talk which is pretty creepy as well and
whenever you know he wants to take her
to the hospital she's like hey I make
good money so I guess this is what kind
of pushes him back over the edge he
realizes that not only does he have to
take this guy
but he's got to do something bigger
because you know the world's just really
screwed up so he ends up going back at
first mr. robot will take him but then
he says if he explains to him what
happened with his father that he'll give
him another chance so Elliott explains
the story and this is really important
going forward he tells them one that he
was a kid he was like eight years old
that his dad was one of the best
computer engineers at evil Corp but they
fired him shortly after he was diagnosed
with cancer
he told Elliott about it but he told him
not to tell his mother and eventually
Elliott ended up telling her and this
created a rift between Elliott and his
dad that lasted until he actually died
it was never resolved and he actually
pushed him out of a window by accident
like he shoved him and Elliott fell out
of a second-story window and ended up
breaking his arm so it's a tough story
like it's the real tragedy and it's you
know whenever you're a kid you can only
imagine like thinking that you broke
your father's trust and then he refuses
to talk to you until the day he dies and
does and goes off dying without ever it
without it ever being resolved in a
weird twist though mr. robot says you
know what did you ever think it was your
fault you broke his trust you know it's
it's really kind of odd at the time when
you watch it you know Elliott basically
says no I was eight years old what are
you talking about I was trying to help
him and you know mr. robot then pushes
him off the boardwalk ground onto the
beach below so it's kind of strange but
it does kind of build the Elliott and
mr. robot dynamic and it's I think
overall that's the good part of it as it
gets to there you know where those two
characters came from we see that mr.
robots pretty unflinching in his when he
sets his mind on something that he's
just going to do it and that Elliott has
some unresolved turmoil under the
surface and he's not nearly as slack in
white you know what I mean he is a he's
a much grayer character whereas mr.
robot kind of comes off as evil after he
puts his pushes him off to the boardwalk
there so it's only the second episode
and overall the
medic is there the look is still there
everything's still good there but you
know there's a couple of things like I
said where the F Society even to the
mask of the F Society I mean it's
obviously very closely related to
anonymous and to me it seems like it's a
little bit especially when I first
watched this I was I was just a little
bit like man that's kind of cheesy but
as the show carried on you know I
started to not really mind that so much
because we find out Sam SML does this in
more ways and sometimes they're good and
sometimes they're not it's not my
favorite part of mr. robot but it does
the job you know what I mean like we
need them to have a identity because of
what happens later and yeah so that
works you know what I mean so I would
have done it a little bit different
perhaps but hey I don't have any TV show
to do it in so it's whatever we did also
meet a side story here that was Ollie
and Angela are outside the record store
we meet this hacker guy we don't know
who he is he's just giving away CDs and
then we realized later whenever he's
trying to put it into his computer that
it's got some kind of malicious software
on it as we see the guy who we know is
Cisco later he is watching as Angela you
know he's watching through the the
webcam he's watching Angela get in the
shower and then he's talking to someone
on IRC or whatever and that is actually
the dark army which is a more serious
Chinese hacker group that we heard mr.
robot mentioned when he was talking
about blowing up that data back up so
that's the main thing that I would say
here is this is not quite the best
episode but it is these there are
important things here the Shayla stuff
is important because the motivation for
Elliot definitely the mr. robot and
Elliot tension is important and we're
starting to see more of what eff Society
has in mind and we got a little bit of
an introduction to the other members of
F Society
Darlene and Trenton Mobley and Romero
we'll get to know them all better before
you know it's important the Tyrell
stuffs a little bit strange we don't
know a lot about him yet I remember when
we when I first watched the season you
know now I know who he is and why he's
important and all that stuff but when I
watched it the first time I was like is
this guy important or what is he's kind
of just a weirdo but hang in there
you'll learn more about him as well he
is in fact taking Terry Colby's place
for the time being he did tell Elliott
that at the beginning so he's in an
important position at evil Corp at the
moment let me know what you think in the
comments of this episode please like
this video if you enjoyed it I'll be
doing episodes three soon I'm gonna
definitely get through all of these
before I get you know before season
three starts I do have another season 3
preview video I was working on this
morning so that'll be coming out
probably before the episode 3 does but
you know just join along it's good to
watch these episodes again follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook and
we can interact over there check out my
patreon please I would love to have you
guys join in over there if you join you
get to help me decide on what to do in
the future videos and get a direct line
of contact to me that is much better
than anywhere else so I think you know I
asked questions to my watchers and
everything else and it'll be a good way
to you know keep things going thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon